you gotta prepare to come prepare the
preparation is key get prepared you have
to be prepared you got to be prepared to
prepare yourself be prepared
hello believed nation today we're going
to talk about how you can always be
prepared to handle anything as you guys
watch this video if there's a sentence
that really resonates with you link it
up in the comments with quotes so other
people can share and enjoy as well I'm
sure Henry I'll tell you inning fighter
on the nose what's happening
you really can't plan to fight it when
you mean the man you never met before
right you just have to get your tools
ready here's a car stops on the highway
they call the triple-a or whatever and
said my car's broke down what is it lady
she don't notice me well the man comes
with all the tools and he come equipped
to handle whatever the problem is
astronaut goes into space and he
pretends that something happens to the
ship before he take off he gets out and
he works on it he's not looking for
something happen but it might happen so
I didn't I just had everything ready now
after the first round being here with a
top professional man so great has sold
me the Knockouts never been defeated
never even scratched I didn't know
really how good he was so I had to come
in actually a little nervous and with
everything ready after one round of
deaths and I found out that this would
tide me out so I would have to resort to
ropes I figured that out after the first
round so I said I'm gonna go to these
ropes and I'm let this man throw
everything he can't let ourself out it
might look like he's winning
if you don't hurt me I will stay here
but if he should be as great as they say
he is if he hits as hard as they say he
hit when he hits your brakes are me
knocked out Joe Frazier I couldn't do it
knocked I cannot he was a big bad job
before the fight you remember and they
remember that don't you yeah
they don't say that never he was a real
bad cat of the day right don't forget
that now after I found out he didn't
have it I stayed there but if he had had
what I thought he had had what they said
here Ida kept running hoping I wouldn't
get tired you do very strong characters
and pretty much everything you have very
strong decisions do you make those
decisions before you start and then kind
of come to the set with what you're
gonna do and then adjust in small ways
are you what the the way I always
approach it is this that I like to have
my own ideas completely worked out so
that if a director I come to find his
working method is that he doesn't want
to talk to me mm-hmm
that I'm not at a loss there's nothing
worse I've seen other actors who stand
in somebody shouts action and they're
just going I don't know what to do I
need they need somebody to come and tell
them what to do I never look at a
director or somebody who tells me what
to do I look at it as someone who we
work together in something and therefore
I need to be responsible too so I have
to bring something to the table and say
I will do it this way if you never say
it if you keep silent this is how I'll
do it and I'll give a few different
versions but it would be it wouldn't
matter if they said nothing how many of
you feel like I've made this talk before
can I see your hand please several
hundred times I made it yesterday you
know what I did between yesterday and
today I spent over six hours getting
ready for the day you see I think it
would be arrogant if I thought I could
stand up and spit it out just because I
did it yesterday or hundreds of times
that's arrogance that's when Buster
Douglas knocks out Mike Tyson that's
when an expansion team in Houston beats
an established NFL team in Dallas I
Danner look at the people here several
thousand I'm taking over an hour to that
several thousand hours of time where
would my integrity be if I came here
unprepared to make something a
presentation that could make a
difference in your life there is no way
you gotta prepare for it ladies and
gentlemen something that I have always
treated golf as I've treated golf as a
sport and because I've played other
sports growing up as a kid and competing
against people who did train in that
sport we all trained physically to
become better able to compete it would
be asinine for someone to go ahead and
not trained to play American football or
for someone not to train to play
basketball so that's why I do all the
lifting is why you know I do all the
running I do all the training that it
takes to become physically prepared to
play to me became much it's become much
more about craft and I think actually on
a smaller scale though I think it's
possible do it on a really big scale but
I think that on a smaller scale I think
preparation is key that I kind of went
back to deciding or sure choosing
preparation over everything and the
amount of time it takes when you have a
lot less money to use you know and you
have to make choices very specifically
and they have to be kind of prepared
much earlier on so that you're free in
you know a very small period of space
you have a lot more freedom because of
all the preparation that you've done
that was about I mean just in terms of
the the process of acting that's what I
I started to learn and I did end of
watch this movie with David Ayer now I
spent five months with police officers
and that was the beginning of realizing
how much I loved preparation
how much I love the process before the
performance and I had always loved that
when I was on stage because there's
always that very formal rehearsal
process that allows you to explore and
use your mind and go to places that are
wrong as well as places that are right
and I love being wrong and right you
know and I love people saying that idea
doesn't really work for this you know
when I'm having an exchange with the
director I love that I love the I love
that kind of I'm bringing an idea and it
gets vetoed or gets accepted whatever it
is it's just the ability to bring ideas
and I see that it's much more possible
to do that within the prep time than it
is in the moment of shooting well you
know you all know management is is I
think it's kind of relentless process so
I guess first like someone said we would
have what happened but changing the
crisis versus before nothing
it's like if you're not prepared for
tough times you're not going to be you
can't like get prepared when times get
tough like you need the army before the
war starts and so that means a
discipline group they know what they're
doing the only real difference is that
the or risk committee used to meet once
a week for a couple hours and in the
crisis of met at 7:00 a.m. 12:00 lunch
time 5 o'clock 10 o'clock 5:00 a.m. that
they had to 24/7 for 6 to 8 months and
we had to say it wasn't very formal we
said hey if you've got a problem go to
the mean and bring the people got to
have and everyone shares the reports it
shares the information tries to react
very quickly you need luck because I
have seen lots of smart people lots of
people who have worked hard they haven't
been blessed and you need luck but at
the same time let's remember Louis
Pasteur's words that God favors the
prepared mind so you have to be prepared
to take advantage of that lock lock you
need but be prepared to seize that lock
if you're gonna get into stuff you got
to be prepared you got to do something
big you know and you gotta you gotta you
know I feel like this power record with
me in lo Wayne it's definitely a
statement record but it's just real this
time it no I mean I tell you all the
time man on my time we won't go as soon
absolutely so how the Brian James a 1 I
don't feel when you're in the gym you
got to go practice work on your jump
shot right work on your game I feel like
or does not need to spend their time in
the studio then just pour it in order
what advice do you have for the future
making great records know what you're
doing study everything it will study
music you know because I was hearing
some funny stuff now that it drove me
crazy I talked to some of the producers
today we were doing an amazing project
in Rabat Morocco last year we had all
the number-one singers in the Arab
Spring Libya Egypt Jordan Aleppo
Damascus everywhere and we're recording
over there and a call no names over
there and I said do you read music he
said yeah I used to but I forgot give me
a break man you don't forget how to read
music but the demand you have to
understand they put the work in to learn
the science man you do you can't play a
trumpet if you don't know how to you
know you have to it's a science of
armatures diaphragmatic breathing it's a
lot of secrets with everything you
attempt to do you know retrograde
inversion the counterpoint
it's been does that say there's only 12
notes man so you can figure out what you
have to do to get your own sound you
have to do that through rhythm melody
and harmony and you got to do a lot of
research to figure that out
you know you have to know what's going
on yet understand I don't know how to
prevail and Albert Bergen Basie and Duke
and Bo Diddley and melly-mel and
Ludacris and Drake and all of you come
on man you know it's a it's doing your
homework man that's all I can say
prepare yourself cuz my thing was I was
all my biggest fear and I don't play
with that word at all
was to get a great opportunity that I'm
not prepared for
so in Frank Sinatra called me man I was
ready for him I'm telling you and he
tests me he's really raycharles super
those guys are rough man Billy Eckstine
Ray Charles Frank synopsis they will
kick your booty you know and he'd say to
me in the first way to an arranged into
Capitol studios you'd say to that first
aid was a little dense no problem man
and I put all armed with trumpets and
arm and mutes full of stems out transfer
the saxophones to the help of flutes and
stuff like let's go he was testing me
only did it three times and after that
he said he knows what he's doing and now
because I was ready for it and that's
the biggest compliment man and
accomplishments you can have in your
life is to say I got my stuff together I
got my together you have to have it
together man you do and this goes back
to my Boy Scout days is be prepared I
know what you're thinking you're already
prepared you've mapped out the rest of
your life the rest of your education
postgraduate work residences residency
residences fellowships clerkships and
you're going to have a long meaningful
career you have all of your plans
already laid down that's not the
preparation I am talking about because
let me tell you the likelihood of you
winding up ten years from now doing what
you think you're going to be doing ten
years from now is probably less than one
in ten the truth of the matter is you
don't know what opportunities are going
to be presented to you you don't know
where you're going to succeed and where
you're going to fail the careers that
you wind up in are invariably going to
be very different so what I would do is
I would focus on how I interact with
people how I approach problems I would
get involved in government if you want
to go into public service I will
recommend you first become a billionaire
but that's another issue
you're going to spend your entire life
doing something different than what you
think and the good news is that
Dartmouth is preparing you for that
because while you think there are
individual subjects what they're really
teaching you to do is to think and to
reason to build relationships and that's
what's going to carry you thank you guys
so much for watching I love snow you
thought of the video which of the clips
had the biggest impact on you and why
what are you going to change now in your
business as a result of watching this
video leave it in comments below and I
will join in the discussion also want to
give a big shout out to Steven Moton or
Martin aqua pronounce that okay Steven
bought five copies on my book thank you
so much Steven he bought one for himself
and for four family members so I really
appreciate that Steven big big ups big
thumbs up to you man and Phil as you
watching if you guys want your chance at
a shout out in the future video make
sure to pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipts super important
so we can keep track thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon